Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Slither.io
Now I've learned a few things about this game including the ability to zoom out
I don't know if that's just because io mods
which was agar.io mods but is now io mods because there's multiple io games now
But THIS, is how I'm going to play it a little bit better than I did before
I'm going to be more aggressive. I'm going to be more-
Oh please don't kill me- I think not!
Heheheheheheheheh, I- I need  to be more merciless is the problem
So wha- what I'm going to do is I'm diving directly into- th- the center of this pool
and I am going after people like it was my job
And also there's something about zooming out
It makes it look like the dots are bigger they actually are just like zoomed out a little bit more
so they look bigger too, they're not worth anymore, but they are just bigger
so i need to, hip-HEPFFF *Evil laugh*
*Evil laugh*
So, that's what I'm going to be doing, and that's the strategy I'm going to employing in this entire time that I'm doing this
Huop, OK, that was a little weird
AHHSHIT
AWE!! what was that? That was lag! That wasn't my fault, that was lag!
That wasn't me!
Awe what a load of ass.
Well this is where I'm going to be embarrassing myself over and over again.
The thing about knowing more about the game is that
I actually realize what kind of dumb luck it actually was for me to get to fourth place
in the last game in the first place, because I was very patient in the last game.
and what I'm not now, is patient.
I am very aggressive, I want everyone to die, except for me
and I want success no matter the cost.
And what that ends up with is a recipe for disaster.
That's going to end with me being dead and everyone being better than me.
Oh well so sad for me.
It still nerve racking I will admit.
There is something about these online multiplayer games
knowing that i'm playing up against real people that always gets my blood boi-
Buhblehbluohblowing
Always blows my blood, it always makes me feel a little bit nervous about what I'm doing
because.. awe heck I'm performing now, people are watching what I'm doing
And then, people are judging me for how bad I am
BUT I'M NOT THAT BAD!!!
I'm pretty decent... I got to fourth place!
And even if I don't do as good as at this time around then all that matters is that
I tried my best
Cuz that's what they taught me in school
*Squeal*
There you go
Oh geez
Aww man that guy lost out
Huup
HA HOOOO!!! Got yoooouuu! Big fiiish
Ahaaaa
oh, geez
geezums
whoa
Ah, OOOOOH NOOO!!!!
AWWW MAAN I swear it's not doing what I'm controlling it to do, it's lagging its not my fault!
This is the episode where I just blame lag for my problems
It's ok
whoa
Hahaa, got you
You were getting to aggressive, a little to greedy
And not quick enough on the fly! Which is exactly the thing that
oooh hello
aaaah
No
Hahaa fuck you! Okay
Now we're doing a little bit bett---Whoa, that guy died
AAH
OOOH COME ON!!
LOCOTRON!
What a load of ass!
This is just bullshit, this is bad show all around for everybody involved
Gimme that
I want it, I'm not big enough to get it
I don't deserve it! I haven't earned it!
I haven't gotten of length
I'm all short and shriveled and not nearly comparative to anybody else.
Aww man that's embarrassing
Ooh, thank you
See I, I like ta, I like ta cry foul when things don't go my way
But in all honesty I understand
It's, it's
That is, that is bizarre
That guy is guy is just spawning out of the aether
He's kinda, man he's to big
Too big!
K just, I'm just gonna wait for someone else to be sloppy
Like that
Cuz everybody is gonna be fighting everybody here
Hup!
Got that guy
A little sloppiness
Never hurt nobody.
Some people just spin in circles whenever they're threatened
It's like a defensive move
They tuck into themselves, and they just orbit nothingness
And hope that everything goes away
But that's not how the world works
Sometimes you got a rampaging Markimoo coming down at ya.
And nobody likes that
Man it is just, it is just loping looping giant snakes wherever you go
*laughs*
Aww
It almost seems like a magical world of fun and freedom
Except its not, its filled with murder and death and, just general bad feelings all around
And everyone wants to kill everyone else
And everyone wants to stand on top of their corpses
So that their success can measure up to everyone elses'
But in reality there's no
There's no proper measurement of success here, it's just
constant never-ending battle of supremacy that's never gonna be won because everyone cycles into an ending, unending spiral of death and despair
AAHH GOD WHYYY?!?!
Anyway.
God, I don't know how I'm gonna be able to keep up with anybody on the leaderboard
Everyone is just, in this server is just astronomically huge
Like the guy in 1st place is literally twice as big, as the guy in second place
Like, how is that even possible?
Aww this guy
This guy dun goofed
*laughs*
He just gave up, he could've spiraled in there but
He just decided
Ehh whatever
I guess it's not worth it
Man, it just doesn't seem like I'm growing as fast as I had before because I'm not coming across death
There used to be a
A lot more death than this around here
There used to be just non-stop death wherever you go.
But now people are wisening up!
People understand the methodology of the game in the short span of time that it's been out!
So I must adapt as well!
Use my brainpowers!
[Deep voice] But that's a very unlikely solution.
Wow, that guy narrowly avoided death.
Oh, no! 'Ls' died!
Okay, the guy in #1 died!
He's no longer supreme!
Maybe he just gave up.
Probably.
'Cause I would've thought that if he would've died, there would've been just,
tons and tons and tons of other people,
like just- like, scooping up HUGE amounts of crap everywhere you go.
[muttering] 'Kay lets see if..
Is he smart enough to go for that?
Nope.
Nnnope.
Haha!
Okay. Got him.
You don't get to-
win off of other people's success!
I get to win off of other people's success!
So right now, I'm in the very heart of the universe
and apparently, I'm just kind of-
What're you doing?
Maybe- *laughs*
Maybe there was someone that saw my name and was like:
"MARKIMOO! OH I GIVE MYSELF TO YOU!!'
which has happened before, or at least I imagine that's what happened, because-
There's really no explanation for the...
rampant suicide that people are shoving themselves inside of me!
Ahh!
Wooh.
That's close.
Nope!
*laughs*
This guy...
Oh yeah, that's so sad!
Oh well.
Wow, okay.
I'll take some of this.
This guy was BIG!
Ok, we're number 45, on the map right now
That's not the best but it's doing better than I was
That is lag.. Lag is not good.
Lag is my death!
If lag leads to death I'm gunna rage quit!
I'm gunna break my keyboard,
I'm gunna smash my computer screen,
I'm gonna dump my computer in hydrochloric acid
It's gonna be bad for everybody involved.
Oh that- Woah
Hello buddy. Good thing he went for that,
And not for me because I wasn't exactly paying attention.
I was just imagining the ways that I'm gonna destroy
My computer (come-pyew-ter) by throwing it off a cliff,
And then dumping it into a ravine, and then
Sending it to the bottom of the ocean,
And then- uh
Fernanfloo! Oh shit.
Wonder if this guy's really-
Is he really silly enough?  Ooo, he's silly enough.
Oop, silly billy! Silly billy!
Got trapped
Hehe
Uh oh
Whatcha gonna do buddy? Whatcha gonna do?
Whatcha gonna do?
Whatcha gonna do? Op well,
Looks like- woah hello
*laughs* Hi rando *laughs*
*laughs* I want you.
I want you inside of me.
Well this is an awkward engagement but,
You know what, I have a funny feeling
That it's gonna end not in the way that you hope it will.
Unless somehow,
Some way- That's right,
That's the end for you.
*evil laugh*
It's a little douchey. It's definitely douchey,
And I think that was another fan of mine,
That thrusts himself, his or her self,
On my snake- EUGHTHSASISA
Alright, we're number 22, we're almost on the leaderboard.
So long as we can hold it together then everything is gonna be okay but,
You know me, that don't happen.
I do stupid things,
ALL the time.
WOAH ok. Bi- Big fish, big fish just died.
Nope, mine mine mine.
hehehehe
NUMBER 19!
And I'll admit this is waaay more difficult than it was before,
There is a lot more going on, there's a lot more competition,
There's a lot more people that are being,
Like smart about the way that they're doing these things so,
I am very disturbed.
I mean it's small change compared to what I have here but,
I'll take it! Oh man, this lag is not favorable!
Don't do this to me, lag. OH GOD!
Don't do this to me! UHH UHH UHHH
Wow, how did he get that guy?
That doesn't make any sense at all.
Wow, that did not make any sense.
I don't know how that happened but,
It was stupid on the other guys part, woah,
A lot of big fish just died,
And I don't know how or why, I'm just gonna swoop in,
Get what I can and get out
Oh boy, wop. How did he die?
NO! OH! WHAT! NO!
WHAT! NO!
THAT WAS NOT WHAT HAPPENED! AHHHHH GOD DAMN IT!
Lag, lag, lag, lag, LAG, lag, lag, lag, lag!
*frustrated groan* I'm gonna b- I- I- l guess I gotta,
Dump my computer in boiling oil now!
I gotta shove it in my buttcheeks and,
Squeeze so hard until it turns into a diamond.
I gotta light it on fire then put it out with more gasoline.
I gotta throw it off the top of a plane while it's flying into a black hole.
I gotta chuck it into a basin of rabid weasels that are gonna chew it to bits.
I've got to punch it with my fists AND my ass,
MY ASSFISTS,
Until it explodes.
I've gotta- fuck.
Either way I'm gonna break my computer now,
Because I didn't do very good,
But either way, that is Slither.io!
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
In the next video, I'm gonna start a party with you guys,
And then you are gonna be the one to blame,
For me being dead.
Sound good? Sounds good!
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
And as always, I will see YOU
In the next video!
Buh-bye!